c'est pas vous vous êtes une chanteuse
du royaume uni ouais et donc ce soir ils
ont voulu faire chacun des chanteurs du
royaume uni alors c'est un toc toc toc
c'est très simple un toc toc toc sais
pas où je dis vous allez voir tout de
suite vous me dîtes si vous ne comprenez
pas la séquence vous levez la main
d'accord si vous ne comprenez pas du
tout la séquence et que vous voulez
partir vous faites comme ça d'accord ok
un moment eh ben c'est parti premier
troc toc toc toc toc
jean-michel mais non on est en train
d'expliquer la en plus
prenez une personne qui sait le faire
merci excuse moi je joue alex mais là on
est ce qu'on est mal tombée on est tombé
sur moi allez-y le deuxième but mais
vous vous dépêchez vous c'est une vive
réplique je suis de tout bas mais pas la
munic
mettez la musique
[Musique]
non
vous
[Musique]
il
alors je peux me permettre
vous avez de babybel sur la tête les
gens d'en parler tout à l'heure et vous
sur la terre
ça c'est une spice girls zahoui a été
dit mais qu'est ce qu'elle irradie well
being erica on dirait attachera n'a eu
des fautes à ferrat non mais sans
déconner c'est vrai mais va faire des
boulettes pas d'attaché
les mecs et regardez regardez ce que ça
fait je ressors en espagne ou non mais
j'ai sur elle soit et d'auxerre
on dirait qu'elles sortent d'un massage
j'ai hâte wide pas là il a épousé vous
doutiez-vous alex c'est un naufrage
alex ce titanic
c'est un outrage un an j'avais aimé ce
qu'ils ont fait spin off
vous avez reconnu des spurs est très
belle équipe mais alors alors elle se
trouve vraiment prendre les prend en
exemple mais vous vous la bnf vous aime
beaucoup cette très belle mais là sur la
tête de ma mère
franchement on dirait que vous êtes à la
peste je suis bénie style aux vendeurs
de the witch et on ne sait vraiment quel
est gentil avec trade aucune merci alex
d'accord merci alex parce que je le peux
te dire tu devrais pas tu devrais pas
allée des prochains rallyes qui est la
thiamine amin qui amène à nous informer
je
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est bien mais on dégarnir et sami de
scooby doo
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
photo permet ça c'est chirac
bah oui mais sans rigoler mais arrêtez
jamais franchement est jamais car semblé
aussi et je vais me remarquer pour
sembler un acteur tout ressemble à
christophe lambert
mais c'est vrai ça s'est toujours fait
dans greystoke non mais sérieux oui a
longtemps leur gré à gré à tarzan mais
sans rigoler c'est vrai que je vous
revoilà maintenant c'est que l'euro va
bien oui bien sûr et on vous connaît on
nous connaît amis alors vous êtes vous
êtes mon ami comme ça mais vous êtes
beaucoup plus mon ami sont tous les tous
les trucs ouais parce qu'on vous
reconnaît pas voilà ce que nous avons
montré il a fait une nouvelle fois
[Applaudissements]
c'est un très bon ami à moi ok il lui
croit ça mais alors est franchement tu
avais la coupe de cristiano ronaldo je
sais pas ce que tu t'es fait là non
messieurs rigoni j'ai fait quoi non mais
c'était beaucoup mieux réaliser j'étais
beaucoup mieux quand je t'avais coiffer
il est vrai les fibres et bien sûr il
était bien sûr à l'arrivée bien sûr alex
vous avez trouvé beaucoup bien se trouve
qu'un maintenant ou avant l'avant non
maintenant cette affirmation
merci alex merci merci alex alors ici
avec vous le dis vous aimez dans le
monde et tous fans de vous pouvez dire
ce que vous voulez si vous trouvez
quelqu'un horrible veut dire sorbonne
d'accord allez toc toc toc qui est là
c'est encore jean-michel en haut on n'en
peut plus alors fais ton truc là à pop
up qui est là tu diego les copies
[Musique]
tha
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors attendez ça sourit et perdu 1 bert
avant le passage alors juste ça c'est le
fun jones a déclaré depuis quand elton
john il a un chapeau marocains ils
avaient les traits sur un sur un titre
vous reconnaissez elton john merci c'est
raul albiol
[Musique]
on attendait donc ça ça pour la
production de chemise c'est john senden
ça c'est dora l'exploratrice ça c'est la
bonne
mais sans rigoler mais quel rapport ça
veut dire soyez tu peux tu peut
interroger le sexe et jean est qu une
petite chanson de diane birch amiable il
parle bien anglais et l'autre c'est
pareil
[Musique]
on dirait qu'ils by one man show
c'est ma place préférée dans ce sens
madame céline sait pas du tout ce que
j'avais dit oui j'adore c'est qu'arrivé
sarko parle je me sens coupable c'est la
chanson la puce chanteur d'angleterre
sous les enterrements et qu'il faut la
plus chanceuse chanter au mariage donc
en terrain qu'avec et mariages et
enterrements et touche une lame docteur
khalit du toc toc toc qui est là
n'entend pas mamie la romaine monde
entier revient d'assumer les droits
d'auteur pour les mariages bien sûr que
ça n'en fait foi moi j'entends lieu à
venir chez vous via prendre l'argent là
bas allez-y alors mais pas les marques
qui est là qui bon
c'est la pause
alors c'est votre job
vous l'avez reconnu vous méritez
vraiment vous appelez byrne comme audrey
comme catharines cette manière si on
vous a demandé par un commentaire
dessiner la baille cherchiez le monde
messieurs merci en tout cas vous êtes
très belle comme ça franchement belle et
je vous jure c'est la venue aux abeilles
mettez-vous à côté de james blunt vous
l'avez reconnu quelque chose quoi elle
me regarda quelque chose je l'aï le bloc
dans la calandre et fernandel est beau
mais ça rigolait beaucoup les dons qu
est ce qu a les dents on peut tout et
même morale et bercy va aller le
prochain rallye
ne serait ce pas le retour de maxime
bien dire qu'elle à 6001 oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
hachey
un bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il a tout donné
il est très bon a dit ward alors on y va
doc gynéco alors d'abord vos toques et
s'il te plaît harry toc toc toc
pour l'instant ça va elisabeth qui s'est
ab ténor non l'état
cette disette en beauté
[Applaudissements]
à
cette langue gynéco c'est là quid des
jeunes comme ça bah oui et les baskets
vont très bien la reine
les cm1 dans ses faubourgs le don c'est
pourquoi wimbledon
oui mais s'il vient des goûts
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
comment ça va mon chéri mais n'a pas
pris des notes sont tes notes dans ma
pole
elles sont là à venir qu'est ce qui
touche la non si tu ne veux pas que
jolis je n'irai jamais car il fait mon
ami non tu peux lire pourquoi la voiture
ne donne pas parce que c'est les mêmes
titres parce qu'en fait c'est les même
temps les jours quelles que soient les
missions pourquoi est on là une immense
star avec nous ce soir à eau
en fait il est fatigué il est censé être
la reine de l'angola fait-elle pas un
plaisir que j'ai écossaise et que je
suis pas de ferrals avant moi le chapeau
bas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]